[Music]
I've never eaten at IKEA before but I've
heard the food is fine I've heard a lot
about the meatballs I think they're
gonna be great the whole premise is
really disturbing to me that a police
even by organizational doors for
silverware and pouches you can also buy
meatballs and cauliflower the value here
is unbelievable and to me that's the
number one most important thing about
food is cost versus taste analysis you
know everyone's talking about how
cauliflower is the new potato this is
what Oliver had in his bowl when he had
to ask for more and I told him no at the
orphanage yeah yeah I dig it I was like
humper yeah I'm into it rule that's the
rule it's not not gold I would say like
I would love to like wake up every
morning with just a spoon of this in my
mouth wake me up
[Music]
so the meatballs are like a flagship
IKEA vegetable this
barbecue here berry sauce our
lingonberries just cranberries if I was
really hungry and this was in front of
me I would eat it
Grammy's a good meatball there keep five
bucks people think for five dollars it's
probably a great deal I'll say that's a
great deal I am glad that they have
veggie meatballs it smells a little bit
like stuffing IKEA has figured out how
to make Thanksgiving into every dish
they make bottoms up
you know what makes it is this butternut
squash sauce is around him stuff veggie
meatballs are good yeah yeah why is
there something water in the beans this
is really beautiful
if there's one thing that's it an even
flight if they're sweet
that's good that's some good Lincoln
yeah I think it is looking very too
highly manufactured but delivers you
know I could eat several pieces of this
I mean we can finish it but I kind of
want to what's kinda like a cranberry
yeah but it's lingering on the vine
it tastes like a pre Sun you can't ever
be angry drinking out of a juice box
Katie likes it it's good it's like
cranberry juice feel like a little more
subtle this would make a great beverage
like a tall coverage I could drink this
all day every day it's also organic so
what huh shut that door value is off the
track the cake and the juice box like
yes everything else and the
lingonberries now a fan I now love
lingonberries this is the kind of food
that you buy like a Disney World in a
prepackaged container because you're
gonna rush and like everybody's already
cranky like no one's happy but it's
there and it's food so we're just gonna
shut up and they're gonna eat it they're
gonna be fine with it they're gonna move
on